Chris Rock was among the 70 000 people
who were stranded in the Nevada desert
during this year's Burning Man festival
after heavy rainfall turned the Solid
Ground into mud blocking vehicle access
and trapping attendees in their tents in
order to make it out to safety Chris
Rock had to hike upwards of six miles
through the deep mud until he was able
to hop in the bed of a truck to catch
his ride out get rid of
it strangely enough Diplo the DJ was
alongside Chris Rock for this entire
Journey DJ and music producer Diplo
posted on social media that he and
Comedian Chris Rock walked five miles
out of the festival before they were
picked up by passing fan
goodness